brigitte macron a ouvert le bal du coup
j'ai fait pareil
brigitte ma croix ouvert le bal du coup
j'ai fait pareil qui a dit ça
et pourtant jamais fait preuve les
constats le trunk non non non nico c'est
non j'en mets ça dans mes les mecs
arrêtez très bonnes réponses de delphine
bien sûr enora malagré j'embrasse
hainaut et donc il s'est confié sur les
tchétchènes non-stop people ok sa vie
privée avec kevin thomas elle se confie
donc sur son coupé avec hugo qui a 7 ans
de moins qu'elle
visiblement elle vient peu mal sa
différence d'âge avec lui ou c'est pas
qu'elle le vit mal à la peur vous avez
vous dire si ça vous dérange surtout
vous delphine qui sentait bien sûr avec
roger qui a on ne compte plus vous savez
quand on aime on ne compte pas l'âge
d'abord ça vous fait pas walhalla
l'enfer un enfer j'ai déprimé mais 40 un
enfer cauchemar je vis très très très
très malsain en plus j'ai un mec plus
jeune je crois que je wati de cougar
même pas trop lamouri gîte macro ouvert
le bal du coup c'est pareil sept 7 ans
attend non ça se sent pas parce que je
suis mature et lui assure notre présent
alors est ce que ça vous fait du bien au
jeu de l'oie géant ma castaldi n'ont
rien donné beaucoup de différence oui
franches mais là c'est pas beaucoup de
sens et c'est en ça va passer de lécher
la joue néanmoins enfin en plus ou moins
comme ma femme mais quand il ya beaucoup
de différences 20 ans 30 ans au sein de
choc delphine vous alors vous avez
combien de différence d'âge avec votre
merci alain de 6 ans ça tient très bien
servi oui j'avais combien d'années tu
nous voient tous les deux ça ne choque
non maintenant seul c'est ça ça me
choque beaucoup non non non mais tant
dans son staff n'ont rien faire
puisqu'il va encore vieux mais quand on
voit une femme de 20 ans qui est avec un
homme de 60 ans oui ça me choque
non mes paroles à rené malleville qui
veut pécho non châtaignes non seulement
ça me choque pas mon beau fils il a ce
talent ne pense qu'à ma fille ouais bah
bravo mr il a fait déserter les travées
au chocolat ya dix ans mais complètement
délirant que ce soit dans un sens ou
dans l'autre c'est le seul l'amour
compte la différence d'âge n'a aucune
importance dans une relation amoureuse
d'abord mais non ça me gênait moins en
moins oui merci